لقد ابتكرت ريكا وعاءًا يمزج بين
السلفادور والطعام الإثيوبي ، ولا
أعتقد أن أي شخص قد فعل ذلك قبل ذلك ،
فلدينا مومباي مارياشي ، وهو
وعاء يمزج بين
الطعام الهندي والطعام المكسيكي أو
وعاء آخر يمزج معًا
جميع الأطعمة من  جميع مناطق البلطيق التي
ولدت في إيطاليا ونشأت في إيطاليا
وأتحدث الإيطالية ثم انتقلت إلى
أمريكا اللاتينية قبل المجيء إلى الولايات
المتحدة التي جاء والدي من النمسا
وجاءت والدتي من ألمانيا
وكلاهما جاء قبل الحرب العالمية مباشرة
جاءت فكرة هذا المطعم من خلال
تكريم أمي التي توفيت أمي
قبل عشر سنوات في العام الماضي وبدأت
أفكر في طعام المهاجرين هذا العام الماضي الذي تم
افتتاحه في 12 نوفمبر ، وهو يقع في
وسط مدينة واشنطن العاصمة على بعد حوالي 50 ياردة
من البيت الأبيض قائمة المشاركة
هي ميزة خاصة بجوار
قائمة الطعام لدينا ، تعال إلى هذا المطعم
، وسنقدم لك أشياء للقيام بها بشكل
ملموس وبسهولة يمكن أن
تترك دولارًا في أمين الصندوق الذي
سنقدم بعد ذلك لمنظمات المهاجرين الخمس الخاصة بنا
أو قد تكون أيضًا
مطاعم تطوعية ، لقد
كنا دائمًا مكانًا يمكن للناس فيه الجلوس
حول الطاولة والتحدث حتى لو لم يكن لديك
نفس الرأي حول الأشياء
التي أعتقد أن الجدل حول الهجرة
في الحقيقة ليس جدلًا أمريكيًا ،
إنه جدل
سياسي سببه نوع من
الجماعات المتطرفة التي تريد جعل هذه القضية في
قضية أكبر بكثير.
جعلت أمريكا
عظيمة مرارا وتكرارا